herzlich willkommen hier bei bild live
an diesem mittwoch an dem wir auf eine
weitere eskalation im krieg blicken
kriegstreiber vladimir putin hält eine
tv ansprache im staatsfernsehen mit der
botschaft an sein land er braucht mehr
soldaten mehr hat eine teilmobilmachung
verkündet die jetzt sofort in kraft
tritt teilmobilmachung
also das ist das wort dieser stunde und
wir wollen ganz schnell herausfinden was
das bedeutete in diesem ukraine kriegt
was das aber auch für uns alle hier in
deutschland an bedrohung bedeutet paul
ronzheimer bild reporter in der ukraine
zu einer blitz analyse dieser ja
bedrohlich klingenden botschaft im
staatsfernsehen der russen von vladimir
putin also teilmobilmachung was bedeutet
hast
du sagst es keinen putin will bedrohlich
wirken das ist sein ziel er will uns
allen angst machen und das macht er vor
allem mit zwei dingen das erste die
teilmobilmachung er will weitaus mehr
soldaten aus russland in die ukraine
schicken um diese regionen dort zu
verteidigen wir haben in den vergangenen
wochen eine gegenoffensive der ukraine
erlebt er will diese stoppen wir hören
von der russia today chefin des
propaganda senders aus russland das ist
da um rund
300.000 soldaten gehen könnte um die
putin hier rein schicken will und das
ist eine ganze menge also das ist das
erste die teilmobilmachung die erneut
mit seinen absurden lügen begründet hat
dass die menschen dort in der region das
den ein genozid droht dass dieser
bereits passiert sei und dass deshalb
russland dort einschreiten müsste das
ist das erste das zweite ist eine offen
ausgesprochene drohung eine nuklear
drohung von wladimir putin das hat er in
den vergangenen wochen und monaten immer
mal wieder angedeutet aber diesmal ganz
klar gerichte dann den westen er sagt
wenn von dort drohungen kommen sollten
in diese richtung dann sollte man wissen
dass russland bereit sei und er sagte
zitat das ist kein bluff er sagt auch
bei der westen will unser land zerstören
und der westen will keinen frieden und
daneben auch dieser satz das ist kein
bluff wie ernst schätzt du diese drohung
ein
wladimir putin hat in den vergangenen
monaten seit beginn des krieges immer
wieder den westen bedroht insofern ist
jetzt eine drohung gegen uns nichts
direkt neues er begründet das damit dass
eben deutschland anderer der nicht
direkt angesprochen hat aber der westen
insgesamt waffen liefere dass man die
ukraine dort ausstatte und er will damit
sicherlich ein signal senden hört auf
die ukraine mit waffen zu unterstützen
er will damit die bevölkerung
verunsichern er will damit sicherlich
auch ein zeichen nach deutschland senden
an diejenigen die ja schon in den
vergangenen monaten immer wieder davor
gewarnt haben und gesagt haben putin
dürfe man nicht in diese ecke drängen
dann könnte das passieren also dieses
lager will er stärken und diejenigen
verunsichert die klar sagen wir müssen
die ukraine auf unterstützt aber paul
damit macht er sich doch jetzt auch
gegenüber den russen ehrlich er spricht
der monatelang von der spezialoperation
jetzt braucht hat 300.000 neue soldaten
jetzt muss er doch auch nach innen von
krieg sprechen oder
er sprach in dieser ansprache weiter von
einer spezialoperation er sprach auch
von einer teil mobilmachung da geht es
um die reservisten also nicht um alle
aber natürlich das ist eine menge an
soldaten kai das ist ein großes risiko
das ist etwas das er immer verhindern
wollte und in wahrheit ist das was
gerade passiert kein zeichen der stärke
sondern ein zeichen der schwäche denn
wenn seine soldaten in kharkiv oder hier
im märz april in kiew gegen die
ukrainische armee nicht so verloren
hätten dann wäre das jetzt alles nicht
nötig was bedeutet dass diese
tv-ansprache putins jetzt für die
ukrainische offensive die ja weiterhin
läuft auch für die region so hans
aus der ukraine aus der staatsspitze aus
dem umfeld höre ich dass das für sie
nichts ändern wird sie wollen
weitermachen sie sagen alle russischen
soldaten müssen aus unserem land raus
aber auch das wird putin versuchen er
versucht durch diese referenten die
jetzt dort stattfinden sollen in lukas
im donalds das ist im osten aber auch in
hessen im süden am schwarzen meer er
versucht dadurch zu sagen das ist dann
russisch also diese referenten gehen bis
mitte nächster woche das in scheinfeld
referenten ich habe das mal 2014 erlebt
wie jemand dort in dort zehnmal
abgestimmt hat also das ist völlig
absurd aber er will dann sagen können
die menschen in diesen regionen wollen
zu russland gehören und wir müssen sie
jetzt verteidigen und will damit auch
die emotionen in russland stärken in
diese richtung
monsheim ans zugeschaltete aus der
ukraine vielen herzlichen dank halt zu
deinen einschätzungen über die
teilmobilmachung die vladimir putin
jetzt angeordnet teilmobilmachung das
ist das wort der stunde wir sprechen
darüber hier im studio mit unserem bild
meinung chef philipp hat auf der lange
der monatelange auch in der ukraine war
was bedeutet jetzt teil mobilmachung für
diesen krieg ja es war ja viel
spekuliert worden ob es zu einer
generalmobilmachung kommt also ob putin
wirklich sagt jeder russische man muss
in die armee muss zur waffe das ist
nicht passiert ist wird eine
teilmobilmachung angeordnet dass das nur
aus einem begrenzten pool von menschen
sozusagen mobilisiert wird konkret ist
die rede von
300.000 russen da sind allesamt
reservisten das hat
verteidigungsminister schäuble
anschließend eine riesige mengen ja das
hört sich erst mal sehr groß sehr
bedrohlich an 300.000 frische soldaten
die bald und in der ukraine an die front
kommen und dort kämpfen aber das muss
man einmal einordnen diese 300.000 man
das sind ja keine
perfekt ausgebildeten kämpfer die nur
darauf gewartet haben an die front
geschickt zu werden sondern das sind
300.000 männer die irgendwann mal in der
armee gedient haben die müssen jetzt
erstmal ausgerüstet werden die müssen
ausgebildet werden und dann an die front
gebracht werden und naja dort müssen sie
irgendwas tun wahrscheinlich kämpfen
aber das können die gar nicht oder
zumindest viele von ihnen nicht dann um
wirklich ein kampf effektiver soll da zu
sein braucht man richtige kampf
erfahrung und die sammelt man nicht wenn
man einfach nur zivilist ist und mal
gedient hat das heißt diese 300.000
jetzt so bedrohlich klingen da kommen
noch einige probleme auf die russische
armee zu wir haben ja gesehen welche
probleme in dem probleme die russische
armee schon hat also logistik ausrüstung
bewaffnung all das kommt jetzt auch auf
diese 300.000 männer zu das ist vor
allem ein eingeständnis von putin diese
soldaten die er bereits geschickt hat
mit denen er innerhalb von drei tagen
die ukraine erobern wollte die reichen
nicht aus und man muss auch dazu sagen
schoigu hat auch von russischen
verlusten gesprochen man hat wirklich
eine bizarre zahl gesagt unter 6000
toten das sind ehrlicherweise 6000 das
waren vermutlich die toten in den ersten
krieg fielen aus etwa also die ukraine
sagt dass es über 50.000 tote
mittlerweile sind westliche angaben sind
etwas niedriger aber alle sagen dass es
weit über 30.000 40.000 tote sind das
heißt diese 6000 die haben sogar unter
russischen
kriegstreiber
propagandisten wirklich für empörung
gesorgt auf telegramm wurde das sofort
kommentiert sowie bitte 6000 also wir
haben hier etwas andere zahlen vorliegen
was macht dass diese mitteilung jetzt im
fernsehen überhaupt mit der
propagandamaschinerie derzeit in
russland man hat nie von krieg
gesprochen jetzt sieht man 300 tausend
reservisten einsetzt kann man dieses
narrativ doch nicht mehr halten
nein putin spricht so immer noch von
einer spezialoperation und solange er
das tut so lange wird sich die
propaganda auch daran halten und die
reagiert natürlich euphorisch das begann
gestern schon also all das was heute
angekündet angekündigt wurde das wurde
propagandistischen in den vergangenen
tagen vorbereitet man hat rhetorisch
immer weiter eskaliert man sprach von
der entscheidenden schlacht man stehe am
vorabend des sieges und genauso wird das
jetzt natürlich bejubelt denn die russen
wissen ja dass diese nachricht in der
bevölkerung nicht für allzu große freude
sorgt denn plötzlich werden ganz viele
familien ihre väter brüder onkel und so
weiter an die front schicken müssen und
die haben natürlich keine lust darauf
war sollten sie auch wenn sie dem krieg
vielleicht unterstützen haben glaube ich
die wenigsten menschen lust selbst in
diesen krieg zu sterben denn viele
russen haben natürlich mitbekommen dass
das alles nicht so gut läuft wie es
ihnen erzählt wird und trotzdem er macht
jetzt zwei sachen eben 300.000 neue
soldaten die kann die ukraine nicht
einfach nach beordern und er droht noch
mal mit nuklearwaffen die wollen wir die
wilde westen auch auf keinen fall
einsetzen also wie beeinflusst das jetzt
den krieg also er hat im prinzip drei
sachen verkündet erstens die blitzaktion
dieser sogenannten teilrepubliken
zweitens die mobilmachung oder die
teilmobilmachung und drittens eben diese
atom warnung die muss man aber auch
einmal erklären er hat gesagt der westen
bedrohe russland auch mit atomwaffen und
müsse deshalb wissen dass auch russland
über ein nuklearer final verfüge und
dann hat er noch ganz ernst in die
kamera geschaut und gesagt das ist kein
bluff nun das hören wir ehrlich gesagt
seit monaten dass russland atomwaffen
einsetzen kann das hören wir von putin
und von seinen schergen das werden wir
auch von ganz vielen propagandisten die
ganz gezielt auftreten um uns angst zu
machen denn angst ist putins stärkste
waffe das ist vermutlich noch viel
wichtiger als die atomwaffe selbst und
putins botschaft die von dem ganzen
auftritt heute ausgeht ist ich werde
diese teilrepubliken annektieren und
wenn die ukraine weiter versucht diese
teilrepubliken zurückzuerobern wozu sich
übrigens hier das recht hat natürlich
dann wird es eine eskalation geben weil
diese teilrepubliken dann ja als
russisches gebiet gelten man muss dazu
aber sagen die ukraine hat auch bereits
die krim angegriffen mehrfach in diesem
krieg und russland sieht auch die krim
als kern russland an und danach gab es
keine eskalation also das ist auch ein
bisschen panik was hier in putins rede
mitschwingt warum kommt die diese aktion
überhaupt jetzt so schnell jetzt am
wochenende soll das referendum
durchgeführt werden weil putin weiß dass
die russischen truppen unter massiven
druck stehen und dass die ukraine bald
dort in diesem teil gruppe blieben
wieder sein könnten und bevor das
passiert will er diese gebiete schnell
annektieren um zu versuchen dem krieg
irgendwie einzufrieren es geht schon
ganz klare signale seitens
bestens auch seitens des kanzlers man
werde das natürlich nicht anerkennen wie
kann er überhaupt dann an dieser
strategie festhalten denn es müsste ja
so aufgehen für putin dass auch die
ukraine nicht versucht ihr gebiet
zurückzuerobern dass er einfach für
russisches gebiet erklärt und das als
ausrede nutzen kann andere waffen
einzusetzen da er das wertet als angriff
auf russisches staatsgebiet
putin versucht auf abschreckung zu
setzen also er will dass bei uns im
westen die botschaft ankommt wenn ihr
die ukraine weiter unterstützt
militärisch unterstützt und die ukraine
mit euren westlichen waffen diese neuen
teilrepubliken die balz russland gehören
sollen angreift dann droht eine massive
eskalation was dann wirklich droht das
weiß niemand wir wissen nicht mal ob
irgendwas drohte putin hat viele
drohgebärden ausgegeben aber diese angst
vor eskalation die soll uns nehmen dank
an bild meinung schiff philippi atdorf
an diesem tag an dem der ukraine krieg
eine neue eskalation erfährt an dem
putin ganz offen droht das alles sei
kein bluff trug mit nuklearer waffen und
der teilmobilmachung die hat er
beschlossen angeordnet danke philipp
[Musik]